yes yes yes hello can you hear me I can
hear you just fine welcome welcome to
the platform okay okay okay so we will
pick it up from uh where the the other
guy left proving Jesus is a Muslim you
want to do
that yeah okay can I sh share my
screen uh
sure okay so you better only show things
that are YouTube appropriate my friend
just to make that
clear otherwise a la might punish
you
okay you have a presentation or
something maybe so it it allows only
sharing uh slides as a presentation only
I cannot share the
screen uh yeah just push present and
then share your tab
yeah but it's asking to upload the
file upload the file yeah this is what
it shows to
me um no no no try try just present and
it should give you when
you you see
it
yeah okay
um about to get a whole presentation
guys no no not not a presentation uh
just uh
oh Nick
says chapter 39
verse2 Muhammad is the first to submit
to a law this proves Jesus was a Muslim
Jesus loves y return to him the
Messiah the
god I the the the thing about those
comments the ones where it's like oh
Adam was the first Muslim Moses was the
first Muslim Muhammad was the first
Muslim what what light doing is at his
time at the at the time man at his time
see relative to the
time where where do you get that
indication my my my very small not very
well research Theory just this is like
like my my uh my opinion theory is that
the Quran has multiple different authors
who just wrote in their own Styles and
their stories necessarily have to
correlate my little
screen yes I see okay so we have a few
points to discuss one second one second
one second
guys that are requesting um if you're
not a Muslim please I mean come on guys
it's the link literally says Muslims
only okay so if you're not a
Muslim not not you bro not you I'm
talking about the other people request
so if you're not a Muslim please leave
the chat here um Firm Foundation looks
like you may be a Christian you're using
you're using original Quran only
Christian lingo which I love so if
you're not a if you're not a Muslim bro
go ahead and watch from from YouTube man
you do me more of a favor watching on
YouTube all right okay go ahead what's
uh we got here we got
this
here so the first point that
shows I'm hearing an echo of my
voice yeah I I hear it
too okay uh can you hear me now I can
hear you okay so said that the first
point that proves Jesus was a Muslim
that he preached monotheism which is
which is the the first billar of Islam
so we have here two Bible verses Mark
12:29 and John
173 uh and in in the first one Jesus
said the most important
one is this here oh Israel the old Our
God the Lord is one nice so he
his Jesus is not talking about himself
he's talking about another entity and uh
he's describing that entity to be Lord
and He describing that entity to be one
right in the other
verse it's saying that now this is
eternal life that they know you the only
true God and Jesus Christ whom you
sent so the other verse which is
explicitly mentioning that Jesus was
sent uh uh by uh the true God okay okay
so let's let's pause there let's pause
there let's start with step one because
I think that that's important okay so
yes step one Jesus preached monotheism
right and we see that he preached
monotheism and so that makes him a
Muslim in step one okay so I'll bring up
the same example that I brought up
previously because monotheism is just
the belief in one God that's what
monotheism is believing in one God right
okay good yes all right so let's say I
believe in one God I preach and believe
in one God I preach about one God but
the one God that I'm preaching about is
my statue that I have in my room am I a
Muslim
uh I'm not sure what is the relationship
between uh this example and the two
verses we are seeing example example
relationship yeah the relationship is
the concept of monotheism so you said in
Step One Jesus preached monotheism so
therefore that makes him a Muslim so I'm
saying okay if I preach monotheism the
idea that there's one God right one God
to be worshiped one God that you should
serve there's only one true God but the
one true God that I'm preaching about is
my statute that I have in my closet am I
am I a
Muslim again again it seems like you are
missing the point we have here two clear
verses H and uh those two clear verses
they are coming from the Bible from the
New Testament and uh in those verses we
have a lot to discuss why bring like a
foreign example here well because we're
going to get to the verses trust me
we're going to get to the vers but I'm
I'm showing you I'm showing you that
your step one is a problem for you
because if you're saying that all you
got to do Step One is believe in
monotheism to be a
Muslim believe in monotheism believe in
one God fine I believe in in one God so
since I believe in one God but the one
God i' I'm saying I believe in is a
statute an idol that I worship am I a
Muslim yes or no my
friend can you bring the your question
again one time one more
time H yeah can you ask the question
again one more
time ask it for me
hi mooha yes yes yes yeah Mo uh Jesus is
a Muslim because he taught
Ted is propagating monotheism yes yes
yes now now monotheism is simply the Bel
in a singular Divine entity or deity
okay okay now if I have a statue in my
closet that I call God and I call that
statue the only God and then I tell you
MOA about my only god statue am I also
propagating
monotheism no you are not propagating
monotheism I only believe in one God so
mono one
God the point here is not propagating
one God the point here is propagating
one God which
is Allah or or the true God or the
Creator W so so that's the definition of
monotheism there we go yes yes that's of
monotheism yes yeah well okay so well
that's actually not the definition of
monotheism but you're saying that the
monotheist when he is believing in one
God he specifically has to be believing
in
Allah right Allah specifically the true
God or theat or the Creator the owner of
the heavens and earth well that's what
I'm saying I'm saying that my statute is
the Creator and the owner of the heavens
and the Earth is is am I a
Muslim no no you Muslim why yes huh why
not that's my one God that I'm a I'm a
monotheist and that's my one God that I
say created all things how am I I think
we we moved uh from that
point no we we didn't we didn't move
from that point you have to answer this
how am I not a Muslim how how am I not a
Muslim MOA I need you to listen listen
yeah how am I not a Muslim if I am a
monotheist that is preaching about the
one God who created all things but he's
my statute that I'm talking about my my
my idol I have in my
CL again the question
comes here
the the
monotheism the monotheism it is uh uh
[Music]
Mo
mooha okay he's going to
call sorry I
got I got a call so monism
is yes can I can I help you MOA let me
be honest with you it's clear that when
you've picked these verses you haven't
actually read the books that they come
from because if you had you would have a
well moha one second one second if you
read the books if you read Mark if you
read John if you read Luke in its
entirety you would have a better picture
of who Jesus is compared to just finding
these one random quotes So mooha I think
what you should do is go and read mo mo
one moment
one
moment
something
goark things then you will have a
clearer idea and not just get
quotes there you
go Ali says it's very funny to see the
difficulty Muslims have in trying to
defend the Quran LOL exactly
Ali avoid discussing those two
verses because there are many meanings
here for example hey Mo look bro if you
if you can't if you can't if you can't
even get past the first look it's
amazing how you have in your number one
like guys we're not kidding he has a he
has a whole diagram a whole like little
notes he numbered them one point number
one boom with his with his bullet points
he has two bullet points we can't get
pass stop talking over me
Mo it's
you if you want to continue to stay on
the stage mute up while I'm no no it's
you who who all right go ahead go ahead
and stay there I'm and stop barking I'm
gonna send you to Mecca to kiss the
stone stop barking you
coward wait for somebody to finish
talking you're good I know the panic
mode is happening I know you got to
manifest but but relax we're going to
help you out I promise we're going to
help you me and Mr daud here are here to
help we're here to help
you so he has Point number one ladies
and gentlemen Jesus preached
monotheism guess
what we can't even get past
that notice how is it possible that
we're talking to a Muslim and and they
Pride themselves they Pride themselves
off of
monotheism pure unadulterated
monotheism and we can't even get past
his step
one we can't do it so mooha I'm GNA give
you another chance stop panicking
relax
relax relax Habibi come back
up and answer the question if you can't
you're out of here it's as simple as
that here's the
question if I pray to my statue submit
to my statute and teach that my statute
is the only God and is the owner and
creator of the universe am I a Muslim
yay or nay Abdul please answer the
question yes or nol you are not a Muslim
this I think we we moved from
this beautiful I'm not a Muslim why not
yes huh why not why
not
because F you you moved from Jesus to to
you not a Muslim if I teach that my
statute no you you move to yourself an
example okay why am I not a Muslim if I
teach that my statute is not the one God
why am I not a
Muslim because we stated that the
monotheism it's related
to obeying
or obeying one God who is the creator
who who is
Allah my statute listen again my statute
I'm saying is the one God who created
all things why am I not a Muslim when I
say that no but but
[Music]
but just take your time it's
okay I think you malfunction we might
have no no we we we be we came over this
many times I told you uh it should be
the Creator the uh the owner of the
heavens and earth who is who is that
specifically because you're saying it's
not my statute so who is that Allah it's
Allah it's Allah got it okay so Allah of
the Quran Allah of the Quran
specifically okay got it all right now
we got somewhere see we got somewhere
now let's go to the verses you quoted
okay let's go to the vers you quoted all
right yeah so the Lord Our God the Lord
is
one uh you are the only true God who
sent Jesus Christ
boom yeah who is the god that Jesus is
talking about how do you know he's not
talking about a
statute um from the context of the uh um
of the Bible it is clear that the entity
which Jesus is talking about is the what
you call in
the in the Bible the father ah you know
what M you are gaining points you lost a
lot of points for me in the beginning
but now you're gaining points back thank
you very
much hold on let me break it down for
the crowd okay so our friend here said
how do we know who the God is that Jesus
is talking about the context of the
Bible tells us so the context here shows
that Jesus is talking about the father
beautiful beautiful okay now is's my
question okay yeah
no before ask can I ask a question here
am I no no this is this is important
sorry this is important and then you can
ask yours right after this okay no
problem no problem ask yours then I will
ask mine right yeah just just don't kick
me
out as long look I promise you this this
is my rule man as long as you are honest
and as long as you are direct and un
topic you can stay as long as you want
no problem good so so what we got here
the context we know that the God Jesus
is talking about is his father here's
the question is Allah the father of
Jesus is what is
Allah the father of Jesus
according to the uh Bible or according
to to my belief according to your belief
huh according to your Bel according to
my belief no he's not the father of
Jesus okay so according to your belief
Allah is not the father of Jesus so here
Jesus is not talking about Allah when he
says that the true God is the father
right he's not talking about
Allah where it is mentioned in the
the true God is the father where it's
mentioned in the in the verse in John
171 because remember you said context
which is why I lik you in John 17 yeah
John 17 because up look on your on your
on your uh on your notes you got John 17
verse3 there verse one verse one tells
us who he's talking to what God he's
talking to specifically okay okay okay
so we pull up John 171 and I have it
right here this what we have verse one
when Jesus had spoken these words he
lifted up his eyes to heaven and said
father the hour has come glorify your
son that the son may glorify
you you see that okay yes follow go
ahead yes so since Allah is not the
father of is not the father of Jesus and
Jesus is praying to who he says is his
father then he's not talking about Allah
right
okay so you asked your question and I I
think I answered or you still waiting an
answer from me yeah yeah I'm waiting an
answer for this is Jesus talking about
Allah I I I I I suppose I gave you your
answer if you still need an answer uh I
still need it I still need it so you
already said that Allah was not the
father of Jesus you already answered
that now the the following question is
this to to sum it up okay since Allah is
not the father of Jesus and Jesus says
that the true God is his father then
he's not talking about Allah
correct according to the context of the
[Music]
Bible what we believe as Muslims what we
believe is any word the word father is
mentioned it is uh referring to the
Creator and it's referring to Allah this
is what we believe as Allah is the
father so then According To Jesus our
perspective huh okay so it sounds sounds
like we're switching back and forth this
why this is why we're stuck here so at
first you said Allah is not the father
of Jesus and Jesus the father of Jesus
yes and contextually Jesus is praying to
his father so Allah is not the father of
Jesus Jesus is praying to his father
therefore he's not praying to Allah he's
not talking about Allah but you're
saying that he is talking about Allah
it is the same you know it's the same
way I think a few days ago I came on Tik
Tok
and I asked you when you uh quoted some
verses in the Quran and I told and asked
you uh in the same context in the same
paper there is another other verses
which are uh giving more important
information which you omitted and you
said you don't believe in the Quran you
said you don't believe in both
verses right don't misrepresent me dud
no no no this is a few days ago when I
came to you and we was talking about
Surah and there was
a um a verse you quoted and when you
quoted that verse you're the one who
said just stop stop when I as when I
who the talking about what did you say
again again to cut
short for for me I I when I when I asked
you who is Jesus talking about when he
says is the true God what was your
answer
mooha I I I I gave you our perspective
as Muslims
that what did you say what did you say
contextually he's talking about no no I
say it yeah yeah I said
that in the context of the Bible that
whenever the word father is mentioned it
means no no no so so you forgot what you
said already so let me help you I asked
you
when stop talking stop talking you don't
even remember what you said anymore you
said when I asked you who is Jesus
talking about when he says the true God
and God is one you said said biblically
in the context he's talking about the
father did you not say
that yes I said that yes okay you said
that I didn't say that you said that so
you acknowledge that Jesus contextually
is referring to his father as the true
God is Allah his father you said no
correct no no no to
[Music]
what the Bible refers to as the father
and we
believe enough of you enough of the
stuttering and stammering that's enough
that's enough when you go back when you
like contradict yourself that much
you'll begin to malfunction and have the
the this
and that's how you're gonna sound when
you are going against what you just said
two seconds
ago and 2300 of us heard this and 500 on
Tik Tok heard you when you just
contradict what you you said two seconds
ago you're G to sound
like That's all folks that's how you're
gonna
sound That's all
folks just be honest if you're honest I
promise you the circuits will not like
get tangled up and and cause you to
malfunction we won't have to push the
reset button and colos you'll be
fineos mooha if you're hearing this
please just go read the entirety of
Matthew Mark L and John and then come
back that's
all Sam is
[Laughter]
stupid oh man I I just I just can't
anymore man